[Music]
they're Marching for their survival
indigenous protesters attending the
annual free Land Camp in Brazil's
capital are demanding the immediate
demarcation of their lands they say it's
the only way to protect their
territories
for us the marsh represents a place to
claim our rights to show that we have
existed for over 500 years the freelance
Camp enables the people of every state
in Brazil to fight for their land rights
and for their existence
just increased threats to their homes in
recent years
deforestation accelerated every year
under former president Cher bolsonaro as
ranchers and miners took advantage of
Black's environmental regulations
during his re-election campaign Brazil's
new president Lula de Silva promised to
Grant protected status to half a million
square kilometers of Amazonian
rainforests
the situation of the indigenous people
in Brazil today is terrible we have been
going through many difficulties mainly
the demarcation of land which today we
do not have that is why we live in this
war our people are fighting without land
and facing discrimination
the Freeland Camp is expected to last
for 10 days
Brazil's indigenous Congress Deputy says
there's been progress since the first
meeting was held 19 years ago
I declare the opening of the Terra Libre
encampment in this house where
indigenous people are no longer received
with pepper spray but through the front
door occupying the National Congress
because if there was no room for
indigenous relatives there would be no
room for an indigenous parliamentarian
Global witness says more than 300
environmental activists have been killed
in Brazil in the past decade but the
fight for their land is a risk these
indigenous protesters are prepared to
take Barbara and gopa Al Jazeera